[Music]
on this Monday night your health in the
heat we have to drink water a lot of
water the dangerous conditions and the
warnings about this Summer's forecast
and Beyond
Ukraine and Russia's historic grain
export deal halted the Domino effects
and what Ukraine's president is now
pushing for
the fight against this frightening
looking vampire fish but lampreys are
slimy resilient beasts how the pandemic
spawned an invasion of this invasive
species in the Great Lakes
kill
consequences defeat save the bees
campaign
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Fara Nasser
thanks for joining us we begin tonight
with the suffocating heat shattering
records and smothering much of the world
right now in the U.S Phoenix has been 43
degrees Celsius or hotter every day for
more than two weeks in Japan authorities
have issued heat stroke alerts in more
than half of the country's 47
prefectures with temperatures hitting 38
degrees in some areas China recorded its
hottest temperature ever on Sunday at 52
degrees and in North Africa and southern
Europe the Mercury is soaring with Italy
issuing hot weather Red alerts for 16
cities including Rome
the World Meteorological organization
says the Mediterranean Heat Wave is
expected to intensify this week and
could last further into the summer
Jackson prosco now on the dangerous heat
leaving this planet in unchartered
territory
they came for a glimpse into the past
across Europe tourists are now sweating
through a moment in history
in Italy officials warn of a critical
situation in the coming days as
temperatures surpass 45 degrees Celsius
it's the same story in Spain weather
I've been it's in Madrid and Croatia
where the beach provides little relief
normally we are at in our room because
it's to have the un's World
Meteorological organization warns the
heat will intensify
and could become entrenched across
Europe through August as climate change
amplifies a warmer El Nino pattern I
think this is a glimpse of of what we
could expect far more of in the future
and not just through El Nino but
obviously in the longer terms with with
climate change as well
in the United States a sweltering summer
is already baked in one third of the
country is under some kind of heat
advisory Miami recorded its first ever
excessive heat warning it's actually not
safe at all while Phoenix reached a
record 18th consecutive day above 43
degrees if you ever like stood next to
an oven while you're baking something
it's like that but like it's coming from
every direction and you can't escape it
temperatures like these are incredibly
dangerous in any location and can lead
to serious illness and death humans have
to regulate body temperature within a
very narrow range heat can accumulate
and then reach those levels that are
really incompatible with with good
health
what's happening now is seen as a
warning of a sweltering summer ahead one
where records are likely to keep melting
away
as the weather nudges toward the
extremes scientists say that many of
these temperatures would not be possible
without human-made climate change they
say what we're seeing now aligns with
predictions for what a warming world
looks like
pharah Jackson prosco in Washington
thank you for that Jackson now those
extreme temperatures are fueling
wildfires around the world and here at
home
there are nearly 900 fires burning in
Canada with roughly half of them in
British Columbia and many of them were
started by lightning more than 100 are
burning in Quebec drifting smoke from
those fires has triggered air quality
advisories and even blowback into the
northeastern U.S prompting air quality
alerts for Millions South of the Border
unseasonably hot and dry conditions
means this year's Fire season started
early and it's showing no sign of
slowing down
10 million hectares of land is burned so
far this year in Canada now that's
larger than the area of New Brunswick
and as Mike Armstrong explains it's a
new record and one that's still growing
the next Premier toured outside the
village of narmetal Monday among the
sites he stopped to see were the massive
fire breaks outside the village trees
that were cut down to keep wildfires
from spreading
last month the town had to be evacuated
when Flames came within 500 meters the
premier now says the province is looking
at permanent fire breaks around other
Northern Communities we are still
studying and trying to evaluate what are
the risks for the next years now in most
of the regions in Quebec that were hit
hard in June things have improved
trouble has moved even further north
several Creek communities have moved out
vulnerable residents fires are cutting
off access by Road and smoke is a
problem there is also a major fire
believed to be bigger than any in
recorded history in Canada fire 218 East
of James Bay has burned more than 8
million hectares you know almost 40
degrees today the winds blowing British
Columbia is right now the hardest hit
region in Canada there are more than 370
fires burning as the province struggles
with extreme drought BC has requested
Federal help the Canadian military has
teams on the ground assessing what's
needed and what it can do it will be
coordinated between the province and the
federal government and also in terms of
what's happening in other parts of the
country as well in terms of the
resources that are available
there have now been firefighters killed
in this Wildfire season a young woman
lost her life in BC last week another
person was killed working in the
Northwest Territory Saturday there's
been record-breaking destruction and
heartbreaking loss in a wildfire season
that's just starting Mike Armstrong
Global News
protesters march to Parliament Hill
today to show their support for those in
Manitoba blocking a landfill as they
demand for the site to be searched for
the remains of murdered indigenous women
enough
not just words anymore we need action
family and friends along with First
Nation leaders across the country are
outraged over the provincial
government's decision not to search the
landfill but as Marnie blunt reports the
blockade remains despite a court
injunction to remove it
a flag is raised and Stands Tall
alongside protesters as they continue to
hold their ground near a Winnipeg
landfill I feel like the world is
watching it doesn't mean that we can
just call that a victory and go home it
means that we just have to continue
screaming louder and get more attention
drawn to what's going on here this about
three days after the city of Winnipeg
was granted a court injunction to have
the blockade removed
on Friday that very injunction was
burned on the spot during tense moments
among protesters but the protesters say
they want to remain near the Brady Road
Landfill peacefully with some saying
this is part of a healing process
for those women that lay in that
landfill
they need to hear our dresses they need
to hear our drums they need to know they
matter
they need to know we care
the Assembly of Manitoba Chiefs speaking
out Monday alongside family members of
Morgan Harris and Mercedes Myron along
with a panel of experts who say the
landfill can be safely searched calling
for action and answers from the Manitoba
premier
they are not garbage
yet they are being treated like garbage
left in a landfill site
no proper burial
no closure for the family
the Assembly of Manitoba Chiefs called
on both the provincial and federal
governments to work with them to find a
way to bring the missing and murdered
women home to their loved ones adding
that they're not asking for a complete
search at the landfill but rather the
specific area where the remains are
believed to be Farah Marnie blunt in
Winnipeg thank you Marnie
Russian President Vladimir Putin is
vowing to respond to a deadly overnight
attack on a vital bridge that links
Russia with occupied Crimea Russian
officials have released this video which
shows the aftermath of what Putin calls
a terrorist attack that killed at least
two people moscow's blaming Kiev and
claims both British and American
officials had quote direct participation
but has not provided any evidence to
back up those claims Ukraine has neither
confirmed nor denied responsibility this
marks the second time in less than a
year that a bridge has been hit by
explosives
and just hours before it was set to
expire Russia's confirmed it will not
renew the Black Sea Grant initiative the
unprecedented and breakthrough wartime
deal allowed grain to safely flow from
Ukraine to other countries for the past
year and as Redmond Shannon explains the
suspension won't only hurt Ukraine but
food prices worldwide
the TQ Samson arrives in Turkish Waters
the last of 1100 ship loads under the
Black Sea Green initiative the year-long
deal expired Monday Russia confirming it
will no longer guarantee the safety of
grain carriers leaving Ukraine's Port of
Odessa I deeply regret the decision by
the Russian Federation U.N Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez says he made
assurances to Vladimir Putin after the
Russian president demanded restrictions
on Russia's food and fertilizer exports
be relaxed that despite Russia's grain
exports Rising since it invaded Ukraine
last year Gutierrez says he will keep
trying there is simply too much at stake
in a hungry and hurting worlds many poor
Nations like Somalia rely on a stable
supply of grain from Ukraine a
spokesperson for Ukrainian leader
Vladimir zielinski says he wants Black
Sea exports to resume even without
Russia on side but that will make
shipping insurers think twice about the
security risks the threat could come
from a frigate or a destroyer or other
warship or it could come from an
unmanned surface vessel Mark gray is a
maritime security consultant he says a
Navy escort or Patrol would be needed to
protect Green Ships from any Russian
threat the Russians would want to make
this very deniable a missile is probably
a good method of doing that because they
could fire a missile and then claim it
was a mine needle member turkey helped
broker the deal if its Navy ended up
engaging Russian warships NATO could be
drawn perilously closer to a direct War
the more likely option for now is to
divert exports via land through Romania
and Poland an extra cost which will get
passed down to Consumers who can least
afford it Redmond Shannon Global News
London
an invasive species lurking in the Great
Lakes coming up how the pandemic spurred
the population growth of sea lampreys
foreign
from the covid-19 pandemic the last
thing most people would think about is
the ecosystem of the Great Lakes for
decades an invasive species has been
kept under control until a pandemic
caused those measures to be reduced
Erica Bella explains why we're seeing
more of the vampire-like sea lampreys
and our great lakes and what's being
done to stop them
it has a snake-like body and suction cup
mouth stacked with rows of sharp teeth
inside there's a file like tongue in the
middle that flicks out and drills
through the scales and skin of the fish
and then it feeds on the fish's blood
and body fluids the sea lamprey is like
something out of a horror film feasting
on the fish of the Great Lakes the fish
is native to the Atlantic Ocean they
spawn in freshwater rivers and streams
but they eventually found their way into
the Great Lakes first documented in Lake
Ontario in 1835 by 1938 they were
established in all five Great Lakes
destroying native fish populations the
use of lamperside along with other
control measures had reduced population
by nearly 95 percent but the lampreys
are slimy resilient beasts that will
take advantage of relaxation and control
and balloon out of control again given
the chance the covid-19 pandemic saw the
relaxation of some of those measures
like Gary and like Michigan we saw a
doubling in the Lamprey numbers and we
saw a significant jumps in lakes here on
in Ontario
um and we saw a large jump in Lake
Superior and it could have devastating
ecological and economical impacts on the
Great Lakes they're just able to kill 40
pounds I think of fish in their 12 to 18
month feeding period the fish in the
Great Lakes are often unable to survive
the sea Library attacks Gaiden says
while this spike is concerning work is
underway through a bi-national sea
lamprey control program to manage
populations we're cautiously optimistic
that while these numbers are high and
economically and ecologically damaging
to the great lakes that they're also
going to be temporary blips in the
numbers with the hopes that in years to
come Lamprey well once again be reduced
to pre-pandemic levels Eric Avella
Global News Toronto
[Music]
honoring history I had the metis
community trying to take back the land
of their former Village
[Music]
the North American indigenous games are
officially underway in Nova Scotia with
the opening ceremony being held last
night which included a not so warm
welcome for prime minister Justin
Trudeau
hello
Trudeau getting booed as he helped kick
off the festivities but it was a
friendlier greeting today for the Prime
Minister as competition kicked off
around 5 000 athletes coaches and
Mission staff from 756 First Nations
across the continent are in attendance
it is the first iteration of the game
since 2017 with the last one postponed
because of the pandemic
every July for the past 30 years
hundreds of Red River metis make a
pilgrimage to a field in Southwestern
Manitoba they're mostly descendants of
what was once a thriving Village until
the government ordered it burned to the
ground in 1938 in order to use the land
as a community pasture now it's a little
known bit of History which is something
the metis want to change Melissa origin
takes us to Saint Madeleine Manitoba
where families gather to feel a sense of
community where their former Village
once stood
thank you
the reminders are still here hiding and
Grazing In Plain Sight
[Music]
you can't get to Saint Madeleine without
passing by I don't think many manitobans
or even Canadians know of this story
where cattle were more precious than
human beings and meaning to metis people
they graze here where 35 metis families
once lived there was a church and a
school a community
all that's left today is the cemetery at
that time families just to move they
used to follow each other they used to
go dig in Santa Cruz
damage he labored for area farmers in
the summer returning to their community
in the fall and when they came back in
the middle of October their house was
already burnt down
and their dog was shot right here their
entire Village gone families scattered
throughout Southwestern Manitoba we had
to rebuild to rebuild with whatever they
had also area Farmers had a place to put
their livestock when you drive in here
and you see those cows
how do you feel
I'd like to have some steak
in 1990 children of Saint Madeleine
residents decided to gather every third
weekend in July to celebrate their
culture and share their history Kim
Smith is an organizer it's really sad
watching all the all the campers stories
it's sad because
then you don't know is it gonna be back
here for a year and this land is just
wasted
the goal having the land returned to the
main team just yesterday I was coming
over here thinking maybe one day maybe
one day my grandchildren will be able to
live here do you ever think about
getting this land back oh yeah
constantly I don't know if we'll ever
get it back or if like others the only
way she'll get to stay here is at rest
that's where my husband is and that
space where you're standing my dear is
my spot
the Manitoba metis Federation has
lobbied The Province to sign over the
land and clear the way for descendants
to come home and rebuild this community
or at the very least memorialize the
site Mickey never give up and so from my
perspective we will get this land I've
been speaking to the premiere on this
matter
where in my view close Premier Heather
Stephenson's office confirms that talks
are ongoing to give this land back to
the Manitoba metis but time is ticking
down to an October an election one that
the NDP opposition is favored to win we
asked them if elected would they give
this land back they didn't respond
Melissa Ridge in Global News State
Madeline Manitoba
I'm Crystal command saying we've all
heard the rally cry that we have to save
the bees but it turns out humans might
be causing more problems I'll explain
coming up on global national
[Music]
for years we've heard the slogan save
the bees and it's truly worked resulting
in a honeybee boom in many parts of the
world like in London which now has the
densest honeybee population in Europe
but as our Europe bureau chief Crystal
commencing Reports it's also led to some
unintended negative consequences
so we're going into Hive eight for
nearly 20 years Dale Gibson has lived
and breathed honeybees creating a
sustainable data-driven business he says
led by his Beats this is a a 14 by 12
plus it's quite a big size Hive and it
requires around 250 kilos of nectar that
nectar is needed to survive the winter
when the bees cluster together they
don't hibernate they also need 50
kilograms of pollen think about a kilo
bag of
flour yeah and then you have to take 50
of those as bees and bring them into a
hive just to survive for the year
without creating a surplus of honey for
The Beekeeper to take is that why when
there are so many of them they don't
Thrive as they're just not able to find
enough nectar absolutely not enough
nectar which is nectares they're
carbohydrate London has the densest
honeybee population in all of Europe
leading to a rise in diseases plus their
overpopulation means other bees species
and pollinators don't have enough food
the population boom can be traced to the
save the bees campaign and the honeybee
colony collapse in America although you
have good intentions you're causing
the opposite of the benefit to
biodiversity that you're hoping to
achieve like the UK Canada did not
experience colony collapse disorder it
was kind of a U.S phenomenon there is
Colony Decline and Paul Kelly a Canadian
honeybee researcher says it's around 35
percent per year but because beekeepers
manage colonies and can divide them they
can rebuild the colony members
pollination is required for a third of
the crops eaten in Canada and of that
Kelly says 80 percent of the work is
done by honeybees whether in Canada or
the UK planting bee friendly flowers
trees and shrubs is the best way for
people to help all pollinators
Crystal commencing global news near
whitam England
and that's global national for this
Monday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our whole crew here I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us tonight's here Canada is
the Vermillion lakes near Banff Alberta
we love seeing your Canada so please
keep emailing us your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
[Music]